this is a production of cornell
university
yeah i want to talk about the genetics
and breeding of resistance to fusarium
ear rod and maize and
yeah the title is not i mean it's kind
of a joke
unfortunately it's not fully a joke
because you know i'm looking back i've
been doing this for
i think we started these experiments 16
17 years ago and
i just feel like if you've been working
on a topic that long you
should know a lot more than i do you
should have made a lot more
progress than i have but um so this is
largely a
history of you know various attempts
we've made at trying to understand this
disease resistance mostly ending in
failure
um but you know hope springs eternal and
the you know sort of the last half of
the seminar is the stuff we're doing now
which we
think might be reasonably effective
figure out how to advance slides
there we go so uh
this is a description of the the
interaction
that occurs between this fungus fusarium
verticillioides which is the
causal agent of fusarium erot and
and maize so if we start over here hope
you can see my little pointer but
you know this this fungus likes to
overwinter and crop residue
and when seeds are germinating it can
infect
germinating seeds and one aspect of
there is a disease called fusarium
seedling blight
same fungus i guess it's a different
disease because it
attacks these little seedlings as
they're coming out of the ground
and it can kill them but what happens
actually much more commonly
is that the fungus will colonize
this uh emerging seedling and actually
become a systemic
symbiont almost um you know i like to
think of it as
basically like an endophyte it grows in
here but it then can
colonize into the um
developing ears and it can take over the
developing kernels and give you the era
now that's one way this can happen it's
probably not the most important way
presumably the most important way that
fusarium causes the ear rot is
through the silk channels so you get
some
some wind rain splash the canadia get
onto the
silks and travel down the silk channel
and they come through the styler canal
this is where the silk attaches to the
developing kernel in the
and that's presumably the mechanism for
how they get in there and then you'll
i'll show you these pictures of the
starbursting in a second which is the
result of that
same fungus also can
get into the stocks and it again it
could have could have been sort of
systemically there
or you could have some insect feeding
that helps it gets into the stocks it'll
rot up the stocks and cause lodging
also you can have insect damage on the
ears
that'll that wounding from the insects
allows the fungus to get in and
colonize that here so there's a it's
just to
start things off with like there's a lot
of different ways this fungus can get
into an into these kernels and cause
this disease or
infect other parts of the plant so
again this is just a little bit better
picture of this ear of of the
fusarium ear rot symptoms this is the
classic one this is starbursting
uh and this is the one you'll probably
see most commonly you have these little
streaks
that are actually caused by the directly
by the fungus itself growing under the
pericarp
um if things really get out of hand that
that fungus can really just destroy the
entire ear and then all kinds of other
necrotropes can get in there and you
know cause a lot of damage
reduces yield and grain quality here's
what the stock rot looks like and of
course that
contributes to lodging so that's a
problem
here's the fusarium seedling blight this
and this is a
paper where they took seeds from this is
from a maze diversity panel
and they they infected or they
inoculated the seeds with physicists as
they were germinating
and they also had a control where they
didn't inoculate the controls basically
look like this one
scale here but then you have these sort
of increasing scales of damage
to the point of where you know basically
nothing even germinates because the
fungus colonizes that seed and
kills it right away so same fungus
same host um and of course we've
screened the same panel for the fusarium
ear rot this thing that you see in the
in the mature ears and so an obvious
question came up is is there a
relationship
between these two aspects of the
of the disease or these two different
diseases caused by the same fungus on
the same host so i ran a little
correlation
on the x-axis we have the seedling
blight score and the y-axis we have the
herot score from the field and
i pretty sure this is as close as i've
ever been in my career
after measuring lots and lots of
correlations this estimate is as close
to zero as i've ever seen so
i mean there's really no relationship
between these two things so
right off the bat you can see that even
though it's the same functions the same
host
um something is very different about
this
as this kind of disease from it versus
the adult plant
i also we also did some studies where we
tried to look at the correlation between
the adult plant ear rot
and stock rot and
we kind of started that experiment and
after splitting a few hundred
corn stalks and measuring a preliminary
correlation
it was not high enough for me to want to
continue splitting
corn stalks because that's just way too
much work so we kind of gave up on that
so it does look like these
these kind of components you know this
ear rot the stock rod and even the
seedling blade are
really kind of different diseases even
though the
fungus is the same so you know that's
the first thing i still don't really
understand what like what is going on
with this fungus it's
kind of crazy um it's in this very
diverse genus
of fungi some of which are pathogens of
corn and other cereal crops
and um we tend to get this fusarium ear
rot
caused by fusarium verticillioides you
know in the southeast
in the southern parts of the country and
in the tropics it's very common
in cooler areas um the gibberella ear
rot caused by fusing graminarium
seems to predominate so they seem to be
these are very similar fungi very
similar diseases but it looks like the
hosts have
sorry the pathogens have different sort
of favorite
environments then there's other species
in the genus that are endophytes of
grasses that are essentially symbionts
they don't seem to be pathogens at all
um and even in corn so maize can be
infected not show any symptoms
or you as i shown you fusarium can kind
of go wild and cause ear rot so even in
uh symptomless ears
and kernels you can find this fungus
it's often there
just hanging out and
you know some folks in the the mycology
pathology community
consider the that there's a continuum
um between endo endophytic lifestyle and
pathogenic lifestyle and fusarium is
somewhere in the middle of this
continuum it can it can sort of
sometimes
be more like just an endophyte and other
times
be like a pathogen and i think that's
that's why this is such a complicated
uh disease and we don't really
understand what tips the balance
to make in a particular case to make
this fungus become pathogenic
so focusing a little more just directly
on the ear rot so i showed you the
starburst symptoms
the other thing that happens with the
fusarium
vertically is growing in the kernels is
it produces the secondary metabolite
humonisin which is a mycotoxin and
that's been linked to cancers and liver
and
kidney diseases both in humans and
animals so that's a bad thing we want to
want to make this disease kind of go
away because of the direct damage it
does but also because of this indirect
effect of
getting the grain contaminated with
these mycotoxins
and here's our here's our big problem
we still have in my opinion near zero
understanding of the biology of
resistance
there's no immunity there's no major
effect our genes
and i'll show you but there is
quantitative variation we don't really
understand
biology so
as i said the most important route of
infection of the
fungus into the developing kernels is
through the silks
so come fungus gets on the silks and it
can move down the silk channel
and it can get in through these um
uh where the silk this is the silk
attachment scar
this is there's a little opening there
early in development where the fungus
can get in and
this in this paper duncan and howard
developed a fusion verticillioides
expressing gfp
so that they could image where in the
kernel this fungus was going after it
infected so you can see there's a lot of
fungus right there at the silk scar and
then it makes these streaks it grows
down the
streaks and it's and it's under the
pericarp
between the alderaan and pericarp layers
and
if you look later in development where
you see the star bursting this is not
actually star bursting because this is
before you can even see the star
bursting but the star bursting
occurs exactly where this fungus is
growing because the fungus is getting in
there and actually
destroying some of the tissue in that
region so
there's this is a beautiful paper where
they did very detailed
uh biology of this and they tried to
compare more resistant more susceptible
um varieties for you know what what's
different between them but it was
actually quite difficult to tell one
one difference was in the silk scar
but it's pretty clear when you even when
you try to drill down to these very
detailed levels that
each of these little components is
probably only playing a small part you
have all these environmental factors
and there's just tremendous complexity
in what this fungus is doing
so so that so the fungus is
kind of has a strange lifestyle and then
and then it produces this mycotoxin
uh like a number of other these serial
infecting
pathogens um probably worldwide
fumonisin is
occurring at um relevant levels
more frequently in grain samples than
probably any other mycotoxin
this is this is a paper where they they
looked at
grain samples from different parts of
the world and whether they were
above some threshold that's you know
specific to the mica toxin depending on
how bad the mycotoxin is so there's
aflatox and af toxins really bad
in parts per billions so it's really
really bad
but fimono sin is is bad you have to be
in parts for millions
but it occurs so much more frequently
that
it might in fact be a bigger health
hazard than aflatoxin
just because it's so widespread here's
north america south america
south africa 92 of the samples so it's
very very common
so why is it making this thing you know
the obvious initial idea was this is
probably a virulence factor
but this is studies from other labs it
appears not to be a variance factor for
fusarium ear rot
it it may in fact be a virulence factor
for that seedling blade there is
evidence for that
for it to infect the seedlings that
fimonous and helps it
do that but it doesn't seem to have any
effect on the ability to colonize
kernels and ears and then
there's this other issue of you get more
mycotoxin in some environments than in
others
so this is a sample of commercial
hybrids grown
you know throughout the u.s corn growing
regions
and no artificial inoculation this is
just
you know commercial hybrids under
regular production conditions
and they got the grain samples from them
assayed them for
um for fimonism and
you can see there's this general trend
for an increase in the levels of
fimonism as you go
to the south and toward the east so so
the hot spot in this study was here in
north carolina in our in our corn
growing region on the
near the east east coast the other thing
i'll just point out
sort of an aside is that even even the
lowest levels in this study um
well not the there was two two sites
that were below the fda recommended
limit
for food and most feed but all the other
sites were above it
and again that's without artificial
inoculation this is presumably a very
common situation
this study was done in the early 90s so
it's pre-bt
and it's clear that having a bt gene um
will reduce the levels of femonisin
because reduces the amount of
insect damage on the ears which reduces
the amount of
disease and fungus in there but it
doesn't solve the problem we still have
and particularly in north carolina we
still have too much femonism in our corn
so there's all these things going on
this is a a little
slice of a of a review from charles
bacon
that again points out that there's this
sort of
fusion bridge virtual silhouettes has
this sort of dual lifestyle as both a
pathogen and a symptomless endophyte
which really indicates the complexity of
this relationship
and again something can alter the
balance of all these factors that are
affecting this relationship
that sometimes push the the fungus
into producing fema all you know getting
more aggressive causing more
ear rot damage but also producing the
mycotoxin
but again since we don't understand
exactly what's causing this
it's hard to really design
you know sort of informed biological
uh approaches to resistance
so so let's talk about resistance and
what are the genetics of resistance and
you know just the common thing here
theme here will be that it's highly
polygenic
lots of environmental influence the
resistance is pretty variable across
populations
really importantly there is no known
immunity so we evaluated the entire
usda pi collection of inbreds
and there was not one in there that we
couldn't at least get a little bit of
fusarium
so there's no there's nothing like an r
gene for resistance
but there are these quantitative
differences in how much ear rot
will be observed in different lines
our big problem here is we we can't
phenotype this thing and the phenotypes
are informative but it's very
labor-intensive it's a lot of work
to get good data on this
so so there is some kind of resistance
but what is it what are the genes
involved these are the sorts of
questions that
you know we we've been very interested
in
um and you know this
brings up this issue of you know it's
you know clearly not primarily
conditioned by like
our gene mechanisms so the question is
is
is there even any active response uh
that's part of the resistance um or is
the resistance just sort of a
constitutive
level it's like as long as the plant has
these factors it's not going to get
infected
uh or is it both you know is there some
component of both of these that there's
constitutive factors and on top of that
maybe there is some active
resistance but again i don't think we
know the answer
to that question been a lot of a number
of qtl studies
and i'll point out laura morales's study
in rebecca's lab that was published last
year that was done in
several nam populations we did this
you know a long back in the dark ages um
i mean the bottom line is you can you
can map qtl
they vary among the populations that's
like the classic story
and there's no really major resistance
genes and even by major i mean
you know if you want something that
conditions 20 25 percent of the
of the phenotypic variants typically not
finding something like that so that
you know the original idea let's map
some qtls and we'll do marker assisted
selection which is sort of how i started
that kind of went by the wayside that
didn't really work so then right
g was came along let's try g wasps maybe
we'll do a better job we'll look at more
diversity again we went to the point
where we
tried to look at everything in the pi
collection
and do a pretty large-scale g-wass on
that
and we have a paper where we've
identified seven snips associated
with the ear rot resistance they all had
pretty small effects
the vast majority of the genetic
variation is just picked up by that
polygenic
background
so and then there's some more studies
that have been more recently you know
people will do another gwas and then
they'll find something different
which also has small effects so again
it's not like we've
hit on anything that you would want to
turn into a marker to use for
selection studies there have been
studies on differential expression
in response to infection
so far these have been limited to two
host genotypes so
i don't i think we can't really
generalize
too much in from those studies as to
what's really going on
so here here's the challenge um we're
trying to breed for resistance
and i've just admitted to you that i
don't really understand anything
about what the resistance is i don't i
don't understand the biology i don't
understand what's going on with the
fungus
um so you know
it's from the point of view of
understanding the biology i'd say really
we i've made very little progress
um but we have this sort of
you know like sort of a halftime plant
breeder so
i can always just switch hats and say
well i'm not going to worry about being
a geneticist and understand
all this i'm going to be a breeder and
i'm just going to select for resistance
and it works
so as long as we have reasonable data
which means you know replication
multiple environments
um and we don't need a huge number of
environments we've typically gotten away
with two reps three to four locations
one year two years data that's pretty
good we'll get heritabilities
that are above 50 on the line means
so we think we can make some progress we
have evidence that we've made progress
and this again tells you that the
genetics are really
important even if we can't identify a
single gene that's
you know really interesting to talk
about or we don't really understand what
the pathways are but we know there is
genetic
variation that uh that
underlies this resistance
and then a couple other little tidbits
that are sort of
sideshows which is kind of goes back to
this idea where
measuring you know inoculating all these
things measuring everything which we do
visually but it takes a long time
it's just a lot of work so if we could
find some shortcuts that would be great
um one of the shortcuts we found for
fimonism contamination is that there's a
very high
strong genetic correlation between the
ear rot and femonism contamination and
we've
we've validated this over numerous
studies
so um selection against iron which is
still difficult to
measure but it is cheaper at least than
than measuring fumonosin
we should get a pretty good indirect
selection response just by
selecting against iran and then laura
laura and rebecca
you know they identified this
relationship between test weight
and higher test weight kind of more
dense
seed is correlated with reduced iron and
fimonous and test weights
you know it's pretty easy to measure
it's pretty fast and it's also
not just visual you put it in a machine
and the machine gives you a number
still we're limited by the
labor-intensive nature of phenotyping
but sometimes these shortcuts are pretty
useful
so so here's sort of like the workflow
of
of doing this evaluating these things in
the fields we have to
um we have to culture the fungus
ourselves
uh we worked with gary payne in the
plant pathology department when we
started but gary has retired so we're
kind of like
abandoned orphan plant breeders with no
plant pathologist to help us anymore
that scares me because
you know again i i don't really know
what i'm doing
as far as i can tell we i know how to
culture
fusarium and um and
so far that's what we're doing and
so we culture our own fusarium grow it
up we make these um
liquid inoculum
solutions and then we'll go so we
actually start over here
we'll about a week after the ears silk
we'll go in and
inject them with the with the solution
with the fungal spores
down the silk channel which we think
mimics a lot of what goes on in
the real world a week later just to be
sure we'll come back and we'll
actually wound them by poking them
through the husks and injecting the
the solution um between the husk and the
ear
that way too so we get a little bit of
wounding so we we're kind of trying to
mimic kind of both of the major pathways
we think are occurring to
[Music]
infection then we have to harvest all
this stuff we bring them into the
seed lab lay everything out all these
ears get scored visually
zero to 100 percent uh
symptoms um and then if we're so
actually if you're doing just irrot
we're done
then you can use any of your data you're
good but if you want to get feminism
data you have to run everything through
the sheller
this is our seed lab set up for this
kind of operation
it's pretty i mean for us this is a big
scale it's a lot of work
you have to then grind all these samples
up and then you have to run elisa assays
which are a couple of bucks
per sample so it's not super cheap and
also this
you know we we've enriched these grain
samples for this toxin that will you
know destroy your liver and give you
cancer so everybody has to work with ppe
and it kind of
it's really a pain
so a little bit on these on these um
indirect uh trait correlations that
that we think are at least favorable
number one here is that we've shown this
in a number of studies now that
if you uh evaluate inbreds
inoculate the inbreds evaluate the ear
rot with the fimonous
and the inbreds you can predict the top
cross hybrid performance of those for
resistance
pretty well if your tester is a is a
susceptible tester
and then we went back and we looked at
this test weight and we thought well you
know what would be really easy
is if you just evaluated test weight of
the inbred line and could that
have any prediction of a hybrid of that
line
for the resistance and actually it
worked um
you have to inoculate to get the best
correlation if you inoculate the lines
that's on the x-axis here here's the
test weight of the inoculated s1 lines
and on the y-axis we have the fer is
fusarium iron
of their top cross hybrid and on here we
have the fumonisin levels of their top
cross hybrid when they are inoculated
and you can see the correlations are
pretty decent
so so that's all great so you know we
thank um
laura and rebecca for like pointing this
out to us because
you know going forward this is probably
something that will allow us to screen
larger numbers
where we can't we don't just don't have
the people power to evaluate all these
ears by eye it does appear though that
we need to inoculate to get reliable
results so so my student eric button is
almost done with this paper which we'll
submit
soon but this you know going back to
this how are we going to do a better job
of breeding
without really understanding anything we
have all these great genomic tools
available to us now
so can we use genomic tools in the
absence of really any biological
understanding
and i'm not saying that's the situation
i want to have i'm just saying that is
the situation we're in
and that's where genomic selection is is
you know should be a
a really good method because the trait's
highly polygenic genomic selection is
good for that it's really a pain
to um phenotype so if we could get
marker data that should be cheaper and
easier than that so
so for all these reasons we were
thinking yeah i mean now's the time
let's
let's see if we can pull off an actual
genomic selection study
on this thing so yeah this is cornell so
i'm talking to a cornell crowd so
you guys know what a somebody who really
knows a lot about genomic selection
looks like there's john luke
and then this is how
i look you know so i'm a little bit old
school
um but this is a you know this situation
even my old school
breeder self um
thought okay now is the time i mean this
is this is the situation under which
genomic selection should be
really useful and i am like i'm just
kind of old and tired
of having to like inoculate all these
things and evaluate all these ears
so maybe genomic selection is going to
be a good approach
so here's how i've turned the corner and
latch myself to the bandwagon just as
it's leaving the station
back up one little step to tell you the
population
where we're implementing this genomic
selection
is a population we developed we call it
refuse for resistance to fusarium
um and it's basically we crossed a
set of lines that have good adaptation
to our region
to a set of lines that have good
resistance mix the whole thing up
random mated everything is tropical or
non-stiff stock so that any lines that
come out of this we can cross them to a
stiff stop tester as a
potential hybrid and we already ran
through three cycles of s1 phenotypic
selection that was done
some time ago and this is the evaluation
this is phenotypic selection evaluation
in this panel we have uh ear rot
and the blue is the cycle three the
sort of red pink is cycle zero where we
started
so the ear rot has gone down and that's
by a pretty significant amount
by these three cycles of phenotypic
selection this is
fumonisin and again the fumonisin
content in the grain gone down that's
due to selection so that's great here's
yield
and yield didn't really change which is
that's fine
i didn't we didn't want to ruin yield we
weren't really selecting for yield we
just didn't want to ruin it
so phenotypic selection works we're
happy uh we can measure it
but it's still it's a lot of work and
the other key thing here is that each
each of these cycles of s1 selection
required two years
uh there is a lag between
you know in our when we have the s1
lines we're evaluating them in the field
we harvest all those ears bring them
back to our seed lab
for example the experiment we've done
this summer we haven't even started
scoring year round we've already
prepared all our seeds for winter
nursery we don't have any data yet
so we lose a generation we can't use
that next winter generation
and so what we have to do is next summer
we'll have the data we'll do the inner
matings and then need another generation
after that to self to get the s1 so
so we end up using two years per cycle
and that you know that's a lot of time
so then we started thinking about uh
okay how can we go forward now with
genomic selection let's build a training
model
using the data we have in hand so this
is my student thiago marino who's
now a breeder in brazil he
evaluated this using um 250 lines from
that
cycle 3 population that we we had data
on
multiple locations in across two years
and then as a validation set we just
generated 200 new random lines
just by selfing out of that same
population so new lines
and we phenotyped them in in a in a new
year
so new lines in our new year's but the
same the same generation the same
population
that they came from everything was
genotyped
talk about that in a second and then you
know then we just did
basically it's our cross validation
where this is our
training set and this is our validation
set uh
the genotyping just as a little aside we
used a modified gbs
this is developed in randy weiser's lab
randy was a student of rebecca's
and um he helped us with that what it
does is it's a further reduction of
complexity so we get
we don't score as many snips but we have
much less missing data
we can call the heterozygotes in these
early generations
better and what should happen is
because you're doing size selection as
part of this we should get a more
repeatable set of snips every time we
redo this in a new cycle
in that base the base population now as
we're calling cycle three
the there's very little population you
know there's a little bit of some family
structure here but
there's actually very little population
structure
it did you know we measured ld there
seemed to be enough ld to
tag resistance even with just 6 000
markers
here's our result so again predicting
into a new year
on new genotypes uh
this i don't want to explain all this
this is some technical boring details we
had two different partitionings of the
data
um and you can see it's it's kind of
okay
it's not great it's not terrible for a
few moment we do a little bit better on
fimonism the heritabilities tend to be
better on humanism because it is
measured
by machine the correlation between the
predicted and observe is 58
and that's an accuracy of 64 so it's
okay
um erot's not as good i don't think
we're quite as accurate there
but even with a correlation of 0.37 we
started thinking man
if we could turn two cycles a year of
genomic selection
as opposed to one cycle every
two years with phenotypic selection in
other words we're doing we could we
could
run four cycles we could run four cycles
of genomic selection in the time we can
do one cycle of phenotypic
that ought to give us some advantage to
genomic selection even though the
accuracies are not super great
so again um if you can get
direct phenotypic observations from
well-replicated
good trials that's the best thing to
select on
but that takes too long so if we can do
genomic prediction faster
that that should work and over time we
should get a greater response to
selection and you know this is
again i'm talking to cornell mark sorel
john luke they've been
pointing this out for over a decade so
we you know we're just
following in your footsteps
here's what we've done we took that base
population
we selected the best 20 lines like we
normally did
purely on phenotypic data so we have we
then just bifurcated the program we had
the ps is the phenotypic selection uh
thing and we took the s1 remnant c to
those
innermate them randomly self so you get
a bunch of s1 lines out of that we
evaluated that
two years ago in three locations
inoculated did our whole shebang
and identified that line the 20 lines
with the lowest fusarium era
we then you know those got intermated
and generated a new cycle we call cycle
five
of s1 lines on the genomic selection
side we had remnant s1c well we every
time i have a little star we did
genotyping and selection
so in this generation we selected among
you know you're segregating s1s we can
genotype those
and get some boost from genomic
selection
we've intermated these guys made a cycle
four s zero
innermated these guys made a cycle five
s zero and then we actually shifted to
alternating
selfing and intermating i'll talk about
that in a second why we did that
well the other thing is in that sort of
uh evaluation of the potential study we
we use the data from the first two years
to predict
the other 200 lines from the last year
but for this
for this thing we actually took all the
data and used that as our trainings
here's the gory details this is for this
is for the genomic selection experts
there
this is like the gap between theory and
and and the practical actually doing of
it at least in
our hands which are not great first off
um if we could get uh our breeding value
predictions before flowering we could
have made twice as much
genetic gain as we actually do this is a
you know this is like a purely technical
point that's a that's like a major
bottleneck industry knows how to do this
they genotype seeds
you know and they they actually make
selections before they even put things
in the field
we're still planting seeds taking leaf
samples
extracting the dna you know it's making
libraries sequencing
and you gotta run it through the
bioinformatics and then you gotta get
the predictions
some of that is easy some of that is
hard
unless you have like unless you have you
know you're an expert with a lab that's
really good at this stuff and there are
labs that are
my life's not so you know this was
challenging for us
so typically we were getting the predict
the breeding value predictions back
you know around harvest or even after
harvest but we'd get them before the
next cycle but not before flowering
so in those first cycles what we did was
we just randomly intermediated pairs of
plants
and we genotyped them and then at
harvest we kept track of the male and
the female we had the predictions for
the male and female parents
so we would we could predict the
breeding value of that
cross the problem was we would have
individuals that we had used in the
inner matings that we tried to genotype
and then the genotyping failed for some
reason so they dropped out
so we just you know we it's not a big
deal for this we just give them a zero
for our breeding values we don't know
what it is
and uh and then we just moved on that
was a little bit
sad that i mean on top of like missing
the
chance to select before flowering we
have this second problem
where we we you know this isn't really
genomic selection as it should be done
this is genomic selection as it gets
done by people who
don't really know what they're doing
like me
having this data though you know for
like quantitative genetics nerds
um the data are a lot of fun um and it
is fun to mess with these data so
this allowed us to implement optimal
contribution methods which are basically
a way to
you can predict how much inbreeding
you're going to get in the next
generation
and we just put a restriction that we
weren't going to increase the inbreeding
coefficient
more than five percent for generation
that might have been too loose
probably was you'll see um and then
you know the hard part about
implementing that optimal contribution
is
you know uh that has to be calculated on
sets
of genotypes not on individual genotypes
so then we implemented a genetic
algorithm
again we didn't invent any of these
things it's just like we're pulling all
these tools that other smart people have
invented
and um trying to put them to use but
that was fun
but also this we have parents that are
contributing to our next generation
where
not only do we not know the breeding
value we don't know the relationships so
we don't
we can't guess how much inbreeding
they're contributing
so that actually really threw a wrench
we had to assume that they weren't
related to anything that's clearly a bad
assumption so
we were not controlling uh
inbreeding very well so
those later cycles we shifted to
alternating and selfing and crossing
because
actually the genetic gain is predicted
to be the same
from that in this condition
um but what it allowed us to do is is
by selfing genotyping and then only
crossing
self progenies that we had the genotypes
on it you know
we didn't have to worry about all this
missing breeding value information
oh this is a really sad story i don't
want to dwell too much but
at some point we actually failed on our
modified gbs
and then we were in a hurry we had to
get data so we had to pay lgc a lot of
money
the genus type stuff and the lgc
genotyping was good but it's
it's expensive so you know clearly for
someone like me who's not a genotyping
expert
like either i need to you know
outsource this to another lab pay a lot
of money find it
find another lab that's really good at
genotyping and partner with them
but i think diy from you know in my case
is
is a bad idea because i think where
where my failings are really on the
on the genotyping side um
since we do have the genotype data on
the selection cycles
um you know we can look at what's
happened in terms of the
relationships and diversity the red dots
here that's the base population
and and these other colors are the later
generations
as we're pushing selection and actually
we saw this right away in the first
generation
the basically in one generation of
it wasn't complete separation but one
generation of genomic selection
really pushed the allele frequencies
very hard very fast
that was a little scary and it you know
it made me a little nervous at first but
um you know we just kept going
um you'll see it this lat this is the
last cycle in blue and it's kind of like
trifurcated into like subgroups i think
that's because
you know we were not going to allow it
to just keep going this way
in the dimensions um because that would
be too much inbreeding
and you can see it on the kinship uh
matrix here's the cycle three
here are the later cycles and then this
is our last cycle here you can really
see we've got some family structure
popping up so
we didn't do a great job even though we
tried we didn't do a great job on
managing inbreeding uh this is my
student student eric button who's
working on this um so
we have samples now of of the
of this initial population and both the
genomic and phenotypic selection and
populations and we have
samples also the intermediate cycles we
planted all those this summer
everything's everything was inoculated
everything's harvested it's all sitting
in the seed lab right now we just don't
we don't have the data yet
um so sorry i don't really have the
answer but you know
we're still pretty optimistic that the
genomic selection was was
at least reasonably effective whether it
was better than the phenotypic or not i
mean we've got to get the numbers
i can't really just eyeball these things
and tell um
will genotype the phenotypic selection
samples just so we can see what happened
to diversity in those
and then we tried to measure a bunch of
you know ear morphology
things that we thought might be related
we'll also look at test weight
just as a way to see what which of these
other sort of indirect
indirectly correlated traits might have
changed with selection
um just the last little bit of theory
going back to theory
this is just a this is a paper from mel
kinger's group a few years ago
where they show that um if you start
with a
you know a training set here at cycle
zero and you start implementing genomic
selection without retraining so this is
just
continuing to use the base population
training set
you know your cumulative gain you know
you're still doing pretty good up
through
you know four or five cycles but it it
really starts plateauing after that so
clearly no matter what we decide
to do going forward we're going to have
to retrain the model but
i think you know before we decide where
we go next i really want to get
we don't want to get the data answer
these questions on how well we did in
terms of
genetic gain from phenotypic genomic
selection
how much diversity did we lose is that
you know how big of a problem is that
now
should we shift away from recurrent
selection to something like
vipre rentals and pedigree selection you
know
everything's kind of on hold until we
until we analyze these
these results and then we'll try to make
an informed
decision going forward so just thanks to
all the
folks who've done all their work jason's
my technician
eric and thiago were the grad students
who did the most recent
work on this and then david charlie
megan and leilani that
they were the this is like a chain of
grad students leilani came in in
2003 and learned how to do all this
stuff and then she taught megan and
megan talk charlie and charlie taught
david
et cetera so it's been nice to have this
chain of grad
students who know what they're doing
since i don't really know what i'm doing
but i'll stop there and i will take any
questions great
thank you so much jim the floor is open
now feel free to use the chat
or just open your mic and
ace laughed at my joke so i appreciate
that
um here rebecca this is ed
do you have any guess as to what the
biology is on the test weight
uh one i mean is it protein
packing on the starch granules or
you know removable water or something
you know
make it more hypoxic or something
i i don't have a hypotenuse rebecca my i
don't have a hypothesis i will say
on top of whatever is actually sort of
intrinsic to
the seed of that line
that correlation is definitely better
when you inoculate
and measure the test weight so some of
the decrease in test weight on more
susceptible lines i think is due to the
fungus getting in there damaging the
kernel and it must be that the
you know whatever mass the fungus is is
is less than the
than the uh corn that you know it's like
destroying the kernel before it can fill
problems
so part of it is part of it is actually
the direct result of infection but
rebecca may have other ideas well i'm
just wondering if
you know the the test weight would
reflect both the genetic differences in
density
or test weight and then also the fungal
fungus induced ones and you know i
i cut we kind of cottoned on to that
hypothesis we're cracking open a lot of
corn curdles and you know there's
pretty much a hole in the kernel we we
did those early cat scans and we could
say like oh look it's
got a hole in it basically this is more
for aflatoxin but
um well we see we we we can really clean
up grain by
sorting out the lightest fraction so i'm
wondering how how does that affect you
when
if it's a kind of con you know
confetti you've got a confounding effect
of inherent density of the different
genotypes and the induced density
difference
yeah i don't know i mean one thing you
could do is you you could measure test
weight
with and without inoculation and yeah
kind of kind of
index of loss of test weight
but i i actually i actually think it is
a bit of both where i think
if you have a line that tends to have
higher chest weight those probably do
tend to be more resistant because we see
the correlation it holds
even without inoculation although even
without inoculation you do get some
fungus
no i you know i've done that little
causal diagram to you i think it is that
the denser stuff
is more resistant you know it's trying
to colonize a diamond basically you know
if you've got a real
50 it's over so we showed this result
actually thiago showed this result that
is had his exit seminar and um
for the folks who don't know you know
major goodman is the corn breeder here
and he's like
he's he's really old school and he's
funny
so his question was since you want
higher test weight he says why don't we
just
grow popcorn everywhere so you know this
sort of idea you can take things to
logical extremes and it it can get
absurd but
the clothes that is kind of my yeah that
was kind of the thought of my question
too but we had this also like by sorting
it sort of
stratified the sample and look at the
ratio of the weights of the lightest and
heaviest
i mean the toxicity of the two i mean
you can get deeper into which one you're
looking at or inoculated non-likely
although not inoculated north carolina
doesn't count for much because it seems
to be
i do have to say you've got a bunch of
questions coming in okay
um uh is she telling you you want to go
ahead and ask
sure well my question is about the
when the fungus leaves as an
asymptomatic
in the fight with the plants does it
still produce their
secondary metabolites thank you
uh my understanding is that yes it does
there are there are
uh there are cases like you can get
this is the scary part of it you can get
a a lot of
corn seed that has no symptoms
of the ear rot or or you can't even
you can't tell that there's fungus in
there there is fungus in there but you
can't tell
visually and in those cases you can
still sometimes
get um reasonably high levels of
of the mycotoxin so yeah it again it's
just as it's not
a simple one-on-one off thing although
the mycotoxin levels
do tend to get higher when you see more
era
that is also true but it's not a perfect
correlation
um jean-luc want to go ahead and
sing out your question uh well yeah
james
jim sorry you showed you
you showed this uh population structure
in that last
generation there's nothing in particular
about optimum contributions that i can
think of that would generate that
but can you explain a bit more
uh i'm gonna also i'm gonna share this
screen so i can show the slide you're
talking about
um this this business in particular you
can really
this is this is this last cycle um
i don't know that i have a great
explanation for it i think
uh i mean the other question is you know
i'm trying to think now that i've given
this seminar
you should ask me what was my population
size and now i'm actually blanking on
that
we tried to get uh we tried to get 384
per cycle but you know there were there
were there were enough dropouts that it
was
below that always so we were probably in
the 250
to 300 range of individuals
you know there's all that number number
of selection candidates
yes and and then we were and then we
were recycling
um crosses between
20 parents so if we were picking f1s we
would pick 10 f1s from 20 parents or if
we were
picking s ones to go to the next
generation
and then so
i i thought that would have been enough
to
avoid that
to avoid the uh extreme inbreeding well
it's not really extreme but to avoid the
inbreeding that we're seeing but
i think you know i think probably
something happened
in the previous cycle where we just
didn't account for it and probably on
some of these samples that weren't
genotyped
so it's not the fault of optimum
contributions the fault of not having
data on
everything that's actually contributing
to the next generation so we were
probably putting in
something like half cib possibly even
full sip
type sets we're contributing to that and
then when you made crosses
between you know this guy that was a
full sip of that guy
they crossed to related things you
started seeing more of a family
structure
i don't think that should happen i think
it's sort of a coincidence but i
yeah i mean i was not expecting that
when i saw that i was like what the heck
is going on
okay thanks uh over to you ace
yeah so thanks jim it's great talking to
you again and hearing your thoughts on
this because you know we also struggle
with these
issues all the time um so i guess like
we know that
you know that fusarium pathogens can
exist symbiotically and like
non-pathogenically and so i think kind
of that
question about like how they transition
into actual full-blown like
infection as opposed to just like
existing in symbiosis
um seems to be like when plants are more
stressed out
they just get come down with like a lot
of
intense infection and a lot of toxin um
and do you feel like because
you know a lot of actual like resistance
genes for a fusion that maybe like
bleeding goals could be better set
towards like
overall ways to reduce plant stress as
opposed to actually breeding for
mycotoxins per se
yeah i mean yes i i think that i think
that's all true
um i mean the best thing you can do
in my observations is don't work with
inbreds
i mean as soon as you make a cross and
you get a reasonably vigorous hybrid
disease goes way down and it's just this
general the plants are more robust
they're more they're more tolerant of
stress
um so so some of the things we've been
doing is sort of intentionally
stressing the plants that's why we
actually want to select on inbreds
because we get so much more variation
yeah i think yeah i think i think
selecting for stress resistance would be
really helpful
i don't know that that's easier i think
it's actually probably harder
than what i'm doing um
and so you know that's that's where the
challenge comes in to really do
um you know to really get
good precise measurements
of of traits that are
truly related to stress resistance i
think that's hard i think that's
actually harder than what we're doing
yeah i mean but you can always like look
at things like ndvi
and other easy and see how well those
kind of things
are correlating with mycotoxins
yeah yeah right so right if it turns out
easy
i mean this is the thing where like if
somebody said i could march a drone
through your field and give you
ear rot data i'd love it
you know that'd be the next bandwagon i
would be the last guy to jump on
um uh you know i guess i'm a little
skeptical that
ndvi i don't know it's empirical let's
we should try
it see what happens it's worth trying
i'm just not you know like all these
things i want to see data before i'll
before i'll really jump on it yeah yeah
i had this idea because danilo in our
lab is looking
if nbi is a better predictor for like
yield depression due to
like actual you know like foliar i mean
working with foliar pathogens then
actual like scoring
pathogens i'm sorry i think i think on
foliar pathogens it's
it's gonna have really good correlations
whether that's gonna translate so well
into the ears i don't know
it's a problem yeah it's a problem
having a disease that's hidden
inside the husks so we can't we can't
image the thing from the sky
so it's recalcitrant to that whole
thing as far as i know until maybe
somebody will invent some wavelength
that will go through the hosks
yeah but because of the connection
between the stress resistance and the
vulnerability or the susceptibility to
these uh
colonizers i mean that's what makes me
feel a little better about measuring
near isogenic lines too that you're not
confounding just adaptation and
maturity and susceptibility
and ace aces seen our fields our
experimental fields
like you know the variation in ndvi is
you know genetics is probably a small
portion of that
a lot is just our we have really not
very uniform fields
a lot of our stations and it's just the
nature of to be so
you know a lot of this work is getting
driven from
by places with good uniform soils you
know
a lot of the midwestern states i think
can do this much better because
it's because they have better uniform
soils
so um jim i because coming back to that
issue of end of fighty uh i still don't
i'm not sure i've ever seen really
compelling evidence for what you and
others sort of always refer to of the
switch
to toxigenicity under stress because it
seems like all the cases in which you
have
toxin being produced or when you have
kind of an
introduction of the fungus into the
styler canal you know as you described
it
or into the roots of the seedling but
once it's an end to fight
this shift to a toxigenic state
particularly in the ear
like do you have reason to believe that
occurs
i mean i'm not i feel like the
colonization's enhanced by stress but i
don't i'm not sure about the switch to
toxicity
yeah i don't know i mean that quote the
quote i showed was from charles bacon
and i think that's where he's saying
that
that it may be you know a weakened plant
is more susceptible to the
to the toxin production yeah i guess i
don't
i don't know yeah i haven't seen that
because that would imply
like a you know a change in the amount
of toxin per unit fungus where it seems
like it's really just a change in them
anyway i i haven't i haven't spotted any
evidence to say there's
sort of this disconnect between fungus
and toxins
it will stress it and then suddenly it
starts producing toxin or starts
becoming an ear pathogen i haven't
really
seen that anyway um anybody else want to
um raise any issues here
anyway if not sort of um we're just on
time so jim i'm just really very
grateful to you and
i was expecting a lovely talk and so
sorry i've got it all so thank you so
much
i really appreciate it yeah we've got
one last question from arcadio in the
chat
oh there we go our kitty over to you uh
sure sorry
um i was just wondering if uh are you
looking at all that rna expression data
to see if there's different kinds of
genes being activated that might be
missing in some of the parents
that could explain the uh basically an
ability of
g was to identify things because uh just
some parents not having a given
background to
allow a positive response to the disease
yeah so we are thinking about this now
we haven't done it
um i have a student who's submitting a
nsf
whatever predoc proposal and he this is
exactly almost exactly what he's
proposing which is
to uh um to take a you know a
reasonably big sample of the typical
maze diversity panel
and look at look at it
expression response to inoculation in
that panel
and and of course the beauty of that
panel is that
ed's group has already generated you
know just
fantastic um tissue specific
um transcriptome data um
from a lot of different tissues so that
it's a nice way where we could say
you know basically how much information
do we gain in terms of being able to
predict whether you're going to get more
resistance or less resistance from this
active response versus
just you know taking the data that ed's
group has already generated
whether it's in seedlings or in an adult
plant but not you know not challenged
with the fungus
you know that may the the difference so
really focusing on the differences in
expression among
genotypes that may have you know maybe
just constitutive
how much of the does that predict the
resistance versus how much gain do we
really get from looking at it at the
uh the kind of active response that
that you could measure that's something
that i'm
you know it's probably a hard experiment
to do well but
something that we're thinking about
might it might be it might be useful to
do
thank you so there's like four minutes
until the graduate student chat starts
so if anybody wants to take a quick
stretch or a break of any kind
now might be the time but meanwhile
let's um
a huge thanks to jim and uh enjoy that
chat with the grad students
and thanks so much
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu